Our final look at quite a patient is brings in all of the other things that are
living in the patient and we can see the difference they make when we look at
their developmental origins.
So now we'll look at the developmental origins of the Microbiota.
A patient is actually a complex community with an ancient co-evolutionary
history.
A patient consists of about 10 trillion human cells,
about 90 trillion bacteria plus uncounted viruses and fungi,
and contains at least 300 times as many unique microbial genes as human genes.
Okay.
C-Sections,
breastfeeding,
and our biotic treatments and hygiene all effect the Microbiota and through
their interactions with the immune system also affect the risk of allergies,
asthma,
obesity,
and autoimmune disease.
The evidence of Coevolution is actually development.
The Gut is the largest immune organ and the development of Gut associated
lymphoid tissue galt gut associated lymphoid tissue is triggered by signals
produced by gut bacteria.
One of those is Salmonella.
The mammals genome has outsourced this essential function experiments on a
scenic infant,
rabbits that is infant rabbits that do not contain any bacteria have
demonstrated that you have to have bacteria in the gut.
To develop the Gut associated lymphoid tissue and they need to be there in the
first week of life in the infant rabbits,
bacteroides fragilis is one of the agents involved.
Then as the organism and its microbiota continue to develop,
there is crosstalk between the Microbiota and the immune system and that helps
to maintain immunological balance.
So this is the role of the immune system in managing the Microbiota,
not just in defending against pathogens but managing the Microbiota.
Mutations in nod receptors which recognize pathogen associated molecules are a
significant risk for Crohn's disease,
which is an inflammatory bowel disease.
So if you interrupt this communication between the Microbiota and the immune
system,
it can induce a disease state and the patient.
If we look at what the gut looks like in a fetus and in a postnatal infant,
the first thing that you can see by comparing these diagrams is that the gut
lumen fills up with bacteria,
but it also fills up with molecules which are being secreted by cells that are
in by specialized cells that are in the gut.
So the maps are microbe associated molecular patterns.
These are communicating them with the gut wall payer's patches or lymphoid
nodules that surround the ilium.
Here is a payer's patch.
Here's a payer's patch.
The panic cells are secreting antimicrobial compounds into the gut lumen.
Here's a pan of cell.
Here are antimicrobial peptides and Immunoglobulin.
A IGA is the major immunoglobulin in gut mucous,
so there is a lot of immune globulin a in the gut mucous,
so a communication system is set up between the host and the complex community
of Microbiota.
The Gut epithelium is protected by an inner mucous layer that is nearly
steroids.
This is astonishing because there is such a huge density of bacteria in the gut,
but the layer that's right next to the gut epithelium is nearly sterile.
The Gut Microbiota live in the outer mucus layer and in the gut lumen,
so this is the small intestine here.
This is the large intestine here.
These blue dots that you see,
blue and green are bacteria.
The of cells are producing antimicrobial peptides.
The goblet cells are producing the mucus and that combination of mucus and
antibacterial peptides is protecting the gut epithelium,
but it's also creating and gut lumen in which the bacteria can flourish.
So the signals from the bacteria can also get through into the gut epithelium.
That microbiota develops across at least two generations.
So before pregnancy begins,
the maternal environment is affecting her microbiota and her own genes are
affecting her microbiota.
She is exposed to different bacteria and she develops her own gut community then
in Utero,
during her pregnancy,
whether or not she's stressed or smoking or what kind of food she is eating,
uh,
what sorts of other factors might be affecting her placenta can all affect her
own microbiota.
And then during delivery,
the delivery method determines which particular ecosystem of bacteria gets
transferred to the infant.
So vaginal delivery versus this area is very important.
Whether or not antibiotics are being used para natally.
So if the mother has given antibiotics before she delivers,
that will perturb her community.
The motive feeding,
breast milk versus formula and the initial colonization of the gastrointestinal
tract.
So it can be shown that children that are born by Syrian have a gut community
that is more similar to their mother's skin,
whereas those that are born vaginally have a gut community more similar to their
mother's Gut.
Then in early infancy,
the infant diet,
which includes introduction of potential allergens and infections will also
caused shifts in the Microbiota found in the baby and if the infant is exposed
to smoke in the environment,
that will also influence this.
So these all combined to determine the state of the immune system.
It's ability in the infant to resist disease and also the ability of the
infant's immune system to manage its own microbiota.
Okay.
Here are some of the data,
so we know that c-sections increase the risk of asthma and eight Hopi is a
hypersensitive allergic reaction that's mediated by Immunoglobulin e.
It usually has a genetic basis that interacts with exposure to the allergen.
Eight is include Excema,
hay fever,
allergic country,
conjunctivitis,
and allergic asthma.
Vaginal delivery leads to an initial colonization by aerobic eco lie and
streptococcus followed by anaerobic back to royalties,
clostridium and bifidobacteria.
Within the first two weeks,
bifido bacteria play a role in the maturation of the secretion of Immunoglobulin
a and saliva,
which may protect against allergy.
Yeah.
So Zarian delivery leads to a much more frequent colonization by Klebsiella
enterobacter and clostridium children born by c section had a 20% increased risk
of asthma and a slight increase in risk of a Topian allergy.
So delivery method makes a difference.
What about obesity?
C-Sections appear to double the risk of obesity in three year old children.
So here are data on percentage of children on the y axis and the bars are
representing either vaginal or Securian birth.
These are the percentages that were overweight and these are the percentages
that were obese.
And you can see that says Zarian foreign children have just about twice the risk
of being obese as do vaginally born children.
Okay.
Breastfeeding also reduces the risk of atopic disorders.
So children with and without a tow fees have different and gut microbiomes.
Breastfed infants are colonized with fewer equally c difficile and bacteroides.
These and then formula fed infants and breastfeeding has two n has to continue
for at least three months to produce these effects and to provide protection
against eight Hopis.
So this particular study,
uh,
followed about 1200 children for about four years and I'll just focus your
attention on this part of the table here.
You can see if we contrast the method of feeding with formula on the top line of
breastfeeding on the bottom line that the frequency of asthma,
excema rhinitis and food allergy is lower for breastfeeding for all of these
different [inaudible].
Now breastfeeding may be reducing the risk of obesity and here is a hypothesis
on how that might work.
It is thought that breast milk is supporting bifidobacteria and increasing full
late infant formula is supporting firmicutes bacteria and increasing butyrate.
The breast milk thereby promotes DNA methylation and the infant formula is
promoting histone acetylation.
They are affecting gene transcription in different ways with longterm effects on
metabolism target genes.
And that might lead to permanent metabolic changes.
So the mechanism,
if this is true,
is epigenetic.
And it might be mediated by continuing differences and gut flora that could be
treated with probiotics.
So one of the hopes for obese people actually is that they could be treated
simply by eating particular kinds of bacteria in their food.
Dealing with the epigenetic mechanisms is not so easy to manipulate.
We also know that antibiotic therapy increases the risk of a Utopian and
obesity,
so any course of antibiotics before the age of two years doubled the risk of hay
fever and Excema in a UK study.
You see that doubling of risk right here between these two sets of lines and
early use of antibiotics increased the risk of obesity slightly but
significantly in humans.
So here are the antibiotics are being given in this gray bar period and the risk
of obesity is going up in the group that was exposed to antibiotics and is a bit
lower in the ones that were not exposed later exposures did not increase the
risk of obesity.
So a piece and obesity both appear to be conditions that are being mediated by
the Microbiota.
You can see the impact of hygiene and on the overall complexity and size of the
microbial community.
By contrast in people who are living in Karelia,
which is now in Russia and living in Finland,
they have similar genetic backgrounds,
but they're living in very different economic and cultural situations.
The people who are living in Finland have much greater incidence of type one
diabetes than the people who are living in Karelia.
And if we look at the rates of Crohn's disease,
which is an inflammatory bowel disease,
the people who are living in Finland have about four times as high a rate of
Crohn's disease as do those in Finland.
And look at the other correlates.
People in Karelia have 73%
incidents of helicobacter.
Those in Finland,
only 5% people in Karelia have about $1,600 a year income.
Those in Finland about $2,500 a year and 73% of the people in Karelia have cats,
only 36% in Finland.
So there are similar differences between the two areas and hepatitis a,
toxoplasma enteroviruses and gut nematodes.
So the take home from this slide is that a dramatic contrast of neighboring
geographic regions that differ quite a bit in their hygiene indicates that they
also differ a lot in auto immune disease,
both type one diabetes and Crohn's disease.
So what are the mechanisms that might mediate this sort of response,
which we're going to go into in greater detail?
The first is just competition.
So the infectious agents could be eliciting strong immune responses that compete
with the weaker responses that are elicited by allergens and autoantigens.
Second,
it could be regulation.
So one antigen suppressive effect also suppresses immune responses to other
antigens.
That's bystanders suppression.
So infectious agents could stimulate regulatory cells to damp,
autoimmune and allergic responses.
The third is innate immunity.
Infectious agents could activate the innate immune system by generating
tolerogenic dendritic cells that activate tolerogenic t regulatory cells.
So this would be a more active manipulation of signaling pathways.
To summarize,
the development and expression of our immune system have coevolved with our
microbiome
interventions that perturb our microbiome,
changed the risk of atopic disease,
autoimmune diseases,
and obesity.
These interventions include c-sections rather than vaginal delivery formula.
Rather than breast milk and antibiotic treatments early in life,
as well as hygiene in general.
The result is mismatched diseases of civilization caused by the inability of
biology to evolve as rapidly as culture.